ich zeige euch wie ihr den perfekten
Pfannkuchenteig ohne Klümpchen macht in
nur einer Minute dafür nehmt ihr eine
große Schüssel füllt da das Mehl hinein
mit einem Schneebesen macht ihr dann in
die Mitte eine Mulde hier kommen jetzt
nach und nach die Eier rein und ihr
rührt mit dem Schneebesen die Eier durch
und nimmt immer wieder Mehl vom Rand mit
dazu jetzt noch Salz dazugeben die Milch
ganz langsam dazu gießen und immer
wieder Mehl vom Rand mit einrühren am
Ende bleibt jetzt noch etwas Milch übrig
die rührt ihr am Ende noch mit dazu und
so habt ihr den perfekten Teig ohne
Klümpchen jetzt kurz abdecken und 30
Minuten ziehen lassen und dann in einer
beschichteten Pfanne ohne Fett oder in
einer Eisenpfanne mit Fett ausbacken